un frente espiritual en una Rusia en pie
de guerra el icono más importante de la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa conocido como la
Trinidad fue instalado este domingo en
la catedral del Cristo Salvador en Moscú
la obra con casi 600 años de antigüedad
se encontraba en la galería de arte
tretiaco Hasta que foxeada por el
presidente Putin a la ortodoxia rusa
ofrecemos alabanzas al Señor y al mismo
tiempo le pedimos ayudar a nuestra
patria también oramos por nuestro
presidente ortodoxo Vladimir Putin por
cuya decisión se devuelve esta imagen
oramos por las autoridades y por nuestro
ejército
el patriarca es un Aliado clave del
mandatario ruso el regalo es visto por
muchos como un reconocimiento al
respaldo que profesa kiril a la
intervención rusa en Ucrania y el apoyo
que granjea entre los fieles para este
fin el traspaso del objeto sagrado ha
generado controversia entre expertos
culturales
en un museo todas las condiciones
especialmente el clima están
establecidas de tal manera que la
exhibición es completamente segura
tienen el mejor ambiente Cuando un
paciente está en cuidados intensivos
todos los especialistas están a su
alrededor
si un paciente se ve privado de estas
condiciones no sabemos cómo se verá
afectada su condición
en tiempos de crisis buena parte de los
rusos se refugian en la fe hacia sus
íconos un aspecto clave en la
idiosincrasia rusa que Putin ex agente
de inteligencia y fiel practicante
ortodoxo conoce e intenta inclinar a su
favor una estrategia que ya utilizó en
abril pasado cuando entregó a sus
generales en el frente de batalla la
copia de un ícono que perteneció a un
ministro de defensa ruso del siglo 19